darn [ __ ] that's always giving me
problems with them that's the last time
I Drive a Chevy I'll tell you that
anyway this week I changed my gender and
went to Planet Fitness so this week
there was a big controversy at Planet
Fitness when this man through person
wanted to use the ladies restroom one
lady felt uncomfortable complained at
which point her membership was promptly
revoked because you know tolerance the
transgender community touts this is a
major victory where many women feel less
safe to those who don't know one of my
first videos ever on this channel was
about Planet Fitness had nothing to do
with transgender people but the fact
that a judgment-free gym ironically
happened to be the most judgmental place
I've ever been in my life they've even
gone as far as to create a lung calar
maz to make athletes or serious trainees
feel uncomfortable unwelcomed and well a
little bit judged so I decided to push
the boundaries and see just where Planet
Fitness is non-judgement of transgender
people ends and their harsh judgment of
successful athletes begins we call this
our true
well your son looks like a father to me
how dare you how dare you
well how are you first-timer I like
everything color branded so I feel like
I step into Star Wars
do you have you don't have a squat rack
at all okay
that's what that would be to close
anything forget the hi forget my head if
it wasn't attached just one thing
careful to your back it's you can hurt
your back it's a little round it just
make sure it's flat I just need just
some help to get the weight up and in
case I just you know just in case for
safety but I should be good
help me get these weights just clap just
help lift him up so there you go one per
Thank You yep
okay thank you okay
I would good think I just need help
lifting off with that
Oh trying to run away I said I was
trying to run away from me it's trying
to get at all
hmm
first day I was flagged as a lunk they
even had bright lights and giant loud
sirens giant loud whistles after this it
was officially banned from Planet
Fitness I try to join another location
but it already been flagged as seen here
but why are you doing that I'm inside
here are you saying that because that's
a pre-transition ID is that why but how
do they know that I'm not sincere
honestly I told them that I want to be a
woman and want to use the ladies
restroom that's about as much proof as
anyone else is providing these days who
are they to tell me that I am NOT a
woman or I don't choose to be a woman
unless we're going to submit all of
ourselves to a physical before we take a
tinkle what's the barometer where's the
line should there be a line at all let
me know comment below this is the point
where we note the Planet Fitness has
been notoriously discriminatory and
actually kicking out people for being
pro-life or for looking too strong the
point here is that no matter how you cut
it somebody is going to end up being
excluded Planet Fitness is emblematic of
the country right now that they've opted
to exclude athletes to exclude
successful people who are serious about
making progress in the gym in order to
include fatties who'd rather eat
seasoned sushi rolls and feel good about
themselves fat drunken stupid is no way
to go through life so everyone should
have a healthy body image you have a
very unhealthy body and you should have
a horrible body image Planet Fitness
even went as far as to remove squat
racks to exclude people who wanted to
squat the most important lift in the
history of man in order to include
people who don't want to squat the most
important lift in the history of man in
this case Planet Fitness has opted to
exclude a vast majority of women who
want to feel safe in changing rooms in
order to include less than point 3
percent of the population simply because
they scream the most loudly and bully
the most effectively but where do you
line up on this issue sincerely let me
know
quick note where are all the rape
culture activists today we're letting
tallywackers into women's locker rooms
I'm telling you you better be prepared
because when I yank it out everybody in
that audience with the exception of my
wife is gonna be running for the exits
so check out our other hidden-camera
experiments and if you want to see more
of Stephanie Crowder
comment below or just leave because I
don't want to do that again I don't want
to do it I'm not gonna do it